here's what would happen if there was
another Earth in our solar system a
second Earth would have to be positioned
in the habitable zone obviously
resulting in the possible binary Planet
system Two Earths of the same size could
have separate orbits with one orbiting
outside of each other think the moon the
Earth and the Sun now we've seen binary
Moon systems before but never binary
planets now since we're talking about
two planets of similar size and
gravitational attraction it's likely
that these Two Earths would switch
positions the Two Earths would either be
sharing an orbit or swapping between the
two imagine if intelligent life forms
that evolved at somewhat the same speed
as humans lived on the second Earth it's
impossible to say whether they would
look the same or act the same or even
speak the same language twin planets
don't necessarily mean twin species but
once you're able to communicate you
could try visiting Earth 2.0 because